on ne peut pas ne pas évoquer tpm paix
qui est quand même à puiser au fond de
fous rires avec le le plus grands riders
du monde c'est quand même si reed et on
va revenir sur une séquence qui est
désormais culte c'est le moment où ils
essaient moon fait par la dorada dollars
c'est vrai que c'est un grand moi
j'étais pas dans l'équipe encore j'étais
dans ma télé et j'ai revu l'extrait la
première émission est géré pleurer de
rire
regardez ces cadeaux c'est pour vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
djamen à ce que la psi et oui les dix ce
qui fait monter at il seulement celle là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
restée très drôle et ce qui est encore
plus drôle c'est la tétanie comprend
deux écrivains on voit pas ou peu
l'expression il est quand même figé
quand il boit udc moon qui rentrent voit
bien que là on doit lui paraît dans
leurs ouailles est pas vraiment ce que
les gens n'avaient de gêner ses
interprètes à lui c'est pas si pourri on
pas mais qu'ils sont très privé de sens
les américains y rigole alphonse le peu
de pas énorme il a la balle aux risques
avec les miens car il se barre parce
qu'ils se préparent ils sont pros et
brooklyn
d'abord incrédule il est dubitatif bien
une tête de playmobil quand même bien
les bras elie semoun il sait pas qui a
dit semoun valérie mais il n'a pas tout
il n'a pas on va faire un petit
florilège des grands moments de fous
rires dans tpm plan et on n'allait pas
que choisir évidemment en tous les cas
il y en a 1 mois qui m'avait beaucoup
fait rire c'était à quelques temps c'est
avec gégé de colère parce que
visiblement il a des gros problèmes des
gros points d'audition
gg oui vous vous voulez venir dans
touche pas vous passez vous me
connaissez oui
[Musique]
gégé est ce que vous allez venir dans
touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
apparemment c'est gilles verdez et
isabelle maury le nord on a retrouvé la
photo de leur fille on l'a regardé
[Applaudissements]
à voir
c'est dégueulasse
elle a prêté le côté ayant fait
désobligeant ces malhonnêtes vers des
applications est ce que vous allez
revenir dans touche pas à mon poste la
semaine prochaine régis me poser gg tu
m'entends c'est denis ja ja cyril
hanouna qui vous récemment si tu vas
venir la semaine prochaine dans son
émission touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
[Rires]
il est tellement c'est un enjeu la
marche au bonheur saiper il y en a trop
et officiels officiel tu enfiles un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gêné si on vous aime dans touche pas à
mon poste ont volé vous le dire gg
gégé est ce que tu viens de la semaine
prochaine dans touche pas à mon poste
est ce que tu veux venir dans l'émission
la semaine prochaine alors vous
connaissez le fou rire dans l'émission
alors on va voir qu'est-ce qui nous a
privés de 500 vous n'êtes pas il faut
que tu m'en sert de contexte
c'est vrai mais c'est lui qui l'a à
l'esprit un peu mal placé des eaux des
oueds va quand même
et moi j'aimerais qu'on revoit quand
même le croisement valeur
[Rires]
et c'était ma gueule c'est pas beau de
vous c'est pas un robot de l'un et
l'autre mais pour autant et c'est tant
mieux à la télé moi je trouve alors
laissez ça c'était le meilleur enfants
destin ever cas incroyable incroyable